thanks Rado now that we know the
distinct advantages of using a ListView
we can use the list view to display the
list of weather forecasts in our app now
which file in the layout folder should
we modify to accomplish this well we
want to add the ListView directly to the
fragment if you open up the fragment
main.xml file you'll notice that the
layout includes a relative layout as a
parent view as well as a child text view
modify this file so that we show a
ListView instead of a text view and
assign it an ID ListView forecast so we
can reference it later also since this
layout only contains one child's view it
would be more efficient to actually
switch to a frame layout instead of a
relative layout after you make the
changes compile and run your app you
will be a little bit underwhelmed with
the blank screen but that's okay that's
because we haven't populated the
ListView with data yet and that will
come in a later step check the box when
you're done